Across all cultures and people, humans have
always had one enduring question: what happens
to us after we die?
As soon as we figured out what death is and
that all humans die (excluding some very special
anomalies), we started wondering what comes
next.
Is there some kind of heaven or hell?
Are we judged based on our deeds in this life?
Or is it just purgatory for all eternity.
Assuming, of course, that there’s anything
at all.
Maybe it’s just nothingness, who knows?
Some people who have had near-death experiences,
like being hit by a truck or having their
heart stop, report going into the afterlife.
But almost all of these claims were retracted
or debunked.
And of course, there’s the famous white
light on the other side of the tunnel that
people say precedes death.
The human fascination with death extends beyond
that, too.
Mythologies all have their own interpretations
of what happens after the physical body stops
functioning.
The Ancient Greeks believed in Hades, a realm
ruled by the god of the same name, where the
souls of the dead would go to be separated
into those who were good in life and those
who were bad.
The good would feast for eternity in Elysium,
while the bad would suffer horrible and poetic
punishments depending on what they did.
The Ancient Egyptians also believed in an
underworld of the dead, though theirs was
different from their Greek cousin.
They believed in the Duat, which was pretty
similar to Egypt itself - it had plains, lakes,
rivers, deserts.
Dead souls would travel down the Nile river
to face judgment, and either be rewarded or
obliterated.
Many Egyptian gods and goddesses were also
said to reside in the Duat.
And some cultures don’t believe in an afterlife
at all - at least, not how most do.
Tibetan Buddhists believe in a cycle of reincarnation.
When someone dies, their soul is reborn in
the body of a new living thing.
One can be reincarnated as another human,
a plant, an animal, or even an insect.
What you’re reincarnated into depends on
your deeds in your past life, interacting
with other reincarnations.
And you can only escape the cycle of death
and reincarnation by reaching spiritual enlightenment:
nirvana.
Needless to say, many cultures have their
unique interpretations of what happens to
the soul and the spirit after your body dies.
But there’s no proof or way to confirm anything,
so it’s all confined to the realm of belief.
There’s no way to reach into the afterlife
and speak to someone, to find out what it’s
like.
Or is there?
Well, that definitely sounds like an anomaly
to me, doesn’t it?
But the SCP Foundation doesn’t just have
one anomaly related to what happens after
you die.
Some of you may have seen our video on SCP-2718
“What Happens After Death”.
It’s an anomaly very, very few people know
about.
The long and short of it is that SCP-2718
is a cognitohazard - once you learn about
it, it infects you.
And when someone infected with it dies, their
mind and soul stay intact after they die.
But they can’t move their body - so they’re
cursed into staying perfectly conscious and
aware of every nerve and sensation in the
body, even as they’re buried and decompose
over decades, without being able to do anything
about it.
Horrible, isn’t it?
Totally!
And that’s why you should watch it immediately
after you finish this video!
Luckily, the SCP-2718 file is safely quarantined
and buried in the database.
It can’t be excised completely, but making
it so that only a handful of people ever have
a chance of stumbling upon it is the best
the Foundation can do to contain this anomaly.
As for those people who do…
well, what can you do?
For a very, very long time, the O5 Council
thought that SCP-2718 was the definitive answer
to the question of what happens after death.
But another anomaly discovered several years
later overturned that answer: SCP-2922 Notes
From The Under.
SCP-2922 isn’t anywhere near as heavily
classified as SCP-2718, so we can read it
safely without worrying about infecting ourselves.
Which is pretty good, considering what it
can do!
But let’s get into it.
SCP-2922 is a Euclid Class anomaly, and consists
of three parts: SCP-2922-A, which is contained
under high security at Area-2922, a small
facility built especially to contain it.
Twenty four hours a day, seven days a week,
one staff member from Project Corbenic has
to be in its containment chamber to answer
any calls that might come from it.
In case you weren’t aware, Corbenic is the
name of the castle where legends say the Holy
Grail is kept and was discovered by King Arthur.
Maybe SCP-2922-A is connected to it?
SCP-2922-C also needs to be researched by
SCP-2922-B, due to its importance to Foundation
operations.
SCP-2922-B seems to be some kind of person,
in that case.
But what does any of this mean?
You see, SCP-2922 is a method of communication
between a human brain and a telephone.
More specifically, it’s a kind of concept
- what the Foundation would call a memetic
cognitohazard.
Those are big words, but think of them as
forbidden knowledge.
Once you learn them, they affect how you think,
and you’re able to act differently because
of them.
You do this in real life, too - when you study
something in a textbook, you’re suddenly
able to use knowledge you didn’t have before.
The only difference is, SCP-2922 allows you
to do something anomalous with it.
Namely, when a subject is “implanted”
with SCP-2922 in a secretive procedure, they
can use their mind to call a phone number!
A specific phone number has to be chosen,
but it can be any number you want.
Imagine being able to dial up your friends
or family without using a phone.
And imagine your phone ringing, only to learn
its someone talking from their mind.
Nifty, but this doesn’t seem terribly dangerous,
right?
The Foundation isn’t quite sure how it works
- after performing research involving SCP-2922-infected
subjects calling phone numbers, they’ve
detected that no radio waves or communication
signals are involved, which is part of why
its an anomaly.
But how would something like this be created?
Well, SCP-2922 was created years before the
Foundation even heard of it, by a small software-development
company.
They were trying to create an app that would
let you send messages to people, and somehow
accidentally created an app that was telepathic
- it could send messages from the mind.
When they realized what they’d created,
they got scared and abandoned and buried the
project, destroying all their copies of the
app.
Well, almost all.
The Foundation heard about the project several
years later and managed to locate a single
remaining copy of the SCP-2922 program from
the depths of the company’s archives.
Even though its an app, it can be used to
call landline phones too.
Which is exactly what the Foundation did.
After a few more months of research and experimentation,
they confirmed that the app wasn’t using
the electric signals of the brain like the
company had thought: it was actual, real telepathy.
They even managed to create a SCP-2922 connection
between a researcher and an office telephone.
That’s what the sub-anomalies are: SCP-2922-A
is a simple landline phone, the kind you’d
see in a receptionist’s desk or in someone’s
office space.
It’s the designation number that SCP-2922-B
can call into.
SCP-2922-B is, of course, the human element
of SCP-2922.
But the Foundation only had one chance at
success at this experiment, because of the
singular copy of the app.
So instead of choosing a random D-class who
couldn’t be trusted or might ruin the test,
they had one researcher volunteer to be host
to SCP-2922: Doctor Janet Spiegel, a woman
who had been with the Foundation’s research
division for over a decade.
She was approved and implanted with SCP-2922.
But what is SCP-2922-C?
Well, that’s Doctor Spiegel’s current
location as of November 11th, 2014.
The Foundation believes she’s not on this
Earth anymore - or even in this reality, but
located in an extradimensional location.
You see, only two months after Doctor Spiegel
was implanted with SCP-2922, tragedy struck.
While driving to work, her car was rammed
by a drunk driver, killing her instantly.
But only two hours later, the SCP-2922-A phone
began to ring.
The researcher picked up the phone, first
answering that the caller had the wrong number
- but was interrupted by Doctor Spiegel, thanking
god someone had picked up.
The doctor thought it was a prank call, but
Doctor Spiegel quickly rattled off her name,
email, password, and social security number.
After her credentials were verified, the researchers
were incredulous.
They had just heard that her car had been
in an accident and that she had died.
Doctor Spiegel confirmed that the only thing
she could remember was driving through snow
and rain, and seeing a bright light coming
toward her.
And then she woke up in the middle of a wide,
flat desert.
Then it hit her that she was really, truly
dead, and wouldn’t be coming back.
Before promising to call back in a few minutes,
she explained she needed time to process the
reality of her situation to the sympathetic
coworkers.
Meanwhile, the Overseer Council approved Project
Corbenic, a Foundation operation to use Doctor
Spiegel as SCP-2922-B to explore and catalogue
what SCP-2922-C was.
If she really was dead, then that would mean
the strange desert she was in… was the afterlife.
The research team were informed of their new
assignment, and the next day, they began to
call in to Doctor Spiegel.
At first, they just wanted to figure out the
landscape of this strange dimension.
During the first call, they interviewed Doctor
Spiegel on her surroundings.
She was still in the large, white desert,
and the sky was a dark sea-green, with black
clouds and no stars.
But the most obvious features were three large,
white moons floating in the sky in place of
a sun.
It was cold, about 10 degrees celsius, cold
enough to make her shiver.
But no wind anywhere.
She also couldn’t see any other signs of
life.
No animals, no people, no wind - no sound
at all.
It was completely silent except for her breathing.
She still had her body, though when asked
about how she felt she couldn’t feel pain,
hunger, or even a need to do anything.
But before they could continue, she asked
if she could speak to her husband.
The researchers told her they’d talk to
the O5 Council about it, and that they’d
try to convince them.
Doctor Spiegel missed her husband, and they
were sure he felt the same about his wife.
Then she offered a plan - she’d walk, infinitely,
in one direction until she saw something other
than desert, then she’d call them again.
The researchers agreed, and Doctor Spiegel
hung up the phone.
Five whole days after that call, the phone
rang again.
The researchers picked it up, only to hear
SCP-2922-B out of breath and panting.
When asked what happened, she started to explain.
She had been traveling through the desert
for five days, though this place had no day-night
cycle, and she hadn’t felt tired or hungry.
Then she encountered a mountain range, and
began to approach its base, when she saw a
life form.
But it wasn’t human.
It walked on two feet and looked like a mammal,
but that was it.
It was some kind of gigantic primate, like
a massive gorilla.
It easily dwarfed the mountains she saw, and
had to have been at least 2km tall.
She had felt it before she had seen it - huge
slow footsteps shaking the ground, then saw
it exit the mountain range.
She saw it had matted black fur and two huge
glowing white eyes, with no mouth.
But then…
it stepped on her.
Not aggressively, just out of curiosity.
It seemed to be investigating her and seeing
how much force she could withstand.
She was crushed flat, of course, but only
a few seconds later her body put itself back
together and she was back to normal.
Then it lost interest and went off into the
desert she had just come from.
The researchers were incredulous at this seeming
confirmation that SCP-2922-C was the afterlife,
but they were interrupted by Doctor Spiegel
saying she could see people making campfires
in a valley ahead.
Hundreds of them, huddled up and some buried
halfway into the ground.
The researchers guessed they were trying to
escape their situation, and Doctor Spiegel
worried aloud that she’d wind up like them.
Then she made another request, citing the
service she had been competently performing
with full loyalty: that she be allowed to
speak to her husband, but the O5s had already
decided she would only be authorized to speak
with other Project Corbenic personnel.
She asked the Foundation to hire him, but
with an art history degree, he wouldn’t
be of use to the Foundation beyond this one
anomaly.
Angrily, she swore and hung up the phone.
The next time they heard from her, the call
was brief and icy.
Doctor Spiegel was clearly still angry over
being denied the right to speak to her husband,
but claimed she had good news.
A wagon being driven by a skeletal horse and
a tall man in a white robe had come to the
human camp.
He informed them that they were being taken
to a place called the “Elysian Fields”.
Remember Elysium, the Greek afterlife from
earlier?
Doctor Spiegel did, and believed that the
man was taking them to a sort of paradise.
The researchers remarked that she didn’t
seem very happy, but she quickly hung up the
phone.
After that strange exchange SCP-2922 didn’t
ring for a very long time.
No further transmissions came in for seven
months.
All attempts to phone Doctor Spiegel instead
rang and rang, but were never picked up.
Project Corbenic was put on hold, until one
day a voicemail came to SCP-2922-A.
The voicemail was recorded by Doctor Spiegel,
but was different in tone from the other calls.
It seemed angry.
She explained that she had been keeping an
eye on the Foundation’s efforts to track
her down, using the fact that she had gained
the favor of some kind of powerful god-like
entity.
She had told the Foundation about the possibility
of an Elysium afterlife, a paradise, and then
knew that they’d want more.
She had lied about the grim reaper, but everything
else had been entirely true.
But what happened after she visited the human
camp was, in her words, far too complicated
to explain.
But she would be more than happy to answer
the Foundation’s questions of what happens
after you die, for a small price.
If the O5 Council let her speak to her husband,
she’d tell them everything.
But if they weren’t willing to accept one
civilian, then she’d know, and would never
tell them the real answer.
She signed off, ending the voicemail.
The researchers were shocked at this sudden
betrayal, and forwarded the request up the
ladder.
But by the time the O5 Council began deliberating
on whether to involve her husband in SCP-2922,
something else happened.
Foundation researchers tracked another voicemail
coming from the same kind of anomaly, except
it was going to Herman Spiegel’s house,
Doctor Spiegel’s widowed husband.
Figuring that she was trying to contact her
husband, Mobile Task Force Psi-8, the Silencers,
raided his home.
But as soon as they threw open the door and
moved in, Mr. Spiegel threw the phone towards
the wall to destroy it, and was shot by the
soldiers.
The phone, however, was unharmed, and still
had one voicemail on it that the Foundation
was able to extract.
The voicemail was from SCP-2922-B, Janet Spiegel,
talking to her husband.
At first, she was assuring him he wasn’t
insane, and that he really was hearing his
wife from beyond the grave.
Then told him to listen carefully while she
explained.
The same godlike entity she had befriended
had worked some magic to allow her to contact
a phone besides SCP-2922-A one time.
She told him that a Foundation task force
was headed to his house and would be there
within ten minutes.
Not just any task force - Psi-8, a squad dedicated
to black-ops executions.
There wasn’t time to run - he would die.
But she reassured him that all wasn’t lost,
even though the situation must be terrifying.
She knew he was an atheist but she was proof
that there was an afterlife.
And not just one - millions of afterlives,
and the one she was in was preferable to most
of the others.
Most importantly, her husband could join her.
He already knew how to get to the afterlife,
even if he didn’t remember.
He’d figure it out on the way.
Her husband listened to her instructions with
rapt attention.
She advised him on the path he should take
once he got to the desert.
He should follow the moon on the left until
he reached the valley where the Striders,
the massive primates, dwelled.
Then he should ask one of the trees where
she had gone, and follow that path.
She also advised him not to do anything to
anger anyone.
Let the Striders kill him, it’s their way
of saying hello.
He’d regenerate with no harm done.
But there were fates worse than death that
he should avoid at all costs.
Getting “sent back”, for one.
But before she could finish her advice, both
of them realized that the MTF were at his
door.
Hurriedly telling him to delete voicemail
so the Foundation wouldn’t find out, she
assured him that she had help from her godlike
friend and that she fully believed in him,
and that he should never give up.
She told him she loved him forever.
By shooting Mr. Spiegel, the MTF had inadvertently
sent him to SCP-2922-C along with his wife.
But the Foundation wasn’t done yet: SCP-2922
had let them set up Operation Galahad, a project
to send trained Foundation operatives into
the afterlife to try and apprehend Janet Spiegel
before she could bring down the Foundation.
Operation Galahad has plenty more stories
where that came from, but we’ll cover those
a different day!
Now go check out “SCP-2718 - What Happens
After Death” and “Project Dammerung - SCP-3448
- Half-Death MRI Machine” for more anomalous
afterlife action from SCP Explained!